all right i want to talk real quick
about something that's making its way
around the interwebs you've probably
heard of it it's called
toxic positivity toxic positivity is an
unrealistic
dismissive overly optimistic
view of the world and here's the thing i
am a to the death
optimist i was raised and trained by
a gentleman named michael shonrock who
was the original optimist that i'd ever
met
and he he he gave me so many
cool uh tips and ideas and perspectives
on how to see the world
in a more optimistic way
but there's a difference between
optimism and toxic positivity
toxic positivity tries to just move away
the ugliness
and the heaviness of life with nah bro
it's going to be cool and good vibes in
these nonsensical pinteresty
instagrammy empty mantras right and
toxic positivity is not the same as
positive psychology
positive psychology is focused on
resilience controlling your mindset
which is
controlling the things you can control
and letting the other stuff go
right always looking towards ways you
can
improve your situation it's about
resilience
it's not about it's all good toxic
positivity creates a false
view of the world it's all rainbows and
butterflies
and puppies and unicorns it's just
immature
quite honestly if you want to live an
authentic life and achieve
anything worthwhile right
anything you got to kill the fantasy
dr andrew young used to tell us all the
time during crisis response
facts are your friends when things are
good and when things are bad
facts are your friends right
if your world's on fire ao2020
acknowledge it acknowledge it
because here's the thing toxic
positivity hurts people who are
experiencing real difficulty
when you say things like dude just look
for the silver lining or
it could be worse or come on man stop
being so negative or
suck it up yo man
don't say those things to friends who
are going through hard things
instead be present listen and just
acknowledge the difficulty they're
facing
when you when you suppress
feelings man when you shove them down
another word for suppress
is depressed right
another word for suppress is depress
don't depress yourself don't depress
your emotions don't depress the people
around you
if people are driving you crazy with
their negativity step away
or ask for permission do i have
permission to give my insight here
hey are you asking me for my thoughts on
this situation because there's another
way we can look at it
and that's different than hey just look
for the silver lining yo
right toxic positivity is naive and
destructive
may we all listen well to those who are
suffering and be people of realistic
courage in the world
is corona wreaking havoc yep
is the economic fallout going to be
devastating yep
does the u.s owe 25 trillion dollars now
we're just mailing people checks for
crying out loud
is that going to serve us well holy
smokes man
no no is there fighting going on
all over the world yep is our country
incredibly divided yep
are neighbors hating neighbors yep
is that a reason to not be optimistic no
it's not
it just means i got my work cut out for
me that means you've got your work cut
out for you
that means that we all have to lean in
this together but denying it pretending
it's not real
is foolish and it hurts people so let's
do away with toxic positivity let's do
away with
living by the instagram quote or the
pinterest quote
or the little wooden sign we hang in our
in our
on the new ship lap in our new kitchens
right
and let's get to the hard gritty work of
being actual optimist of actually
working hard to change our situations
for the better
being resilient honoring people and
sometimes just sitting with people and
saying thanks for sharing
sucks
thanks for sharing i'll be praying for
you
how can i help